stell dir vor du könntest von jedem
objekt in einem haushalt die farbe
ändern
stell dir vor du könntest manipulieren
wie licht mit objekten interagieren
klingt wie die zukunft oder vor ein paar
wochen war ich in karlsruhe auf der
couch einer messe für
startup-unternehmen ich habe mich damit
vielen jungen unternehmern unterhalten
die mir alle von ihren erfindungen und
ideen für die zukunft erzählt haben
und einer davon hat mich besonders
beeindruckt peyman hossein mohseni haben
des city of water technologies peyman
hat lange an einer idee gearbeitet die
so genial ist dass sie 2014 in der
renommierten wissenschaftszeitschrift
nature veröffentlicht wurde
eine technologie mit der man nicht
beeinflussen kann
[Musik]
wenn licht auf ein objekt trifft dann
wird es immer zu einem teil absorbiert
und zu einem anderen teil reflektiert
ein objekte wie ein spiegel reflektiert
das meiste licht deswegen kann man auf
der spiegel oberfläche andere objekte
sehen
ein bunter gegenstand wie zb ein roter
schal absolviert hingegen das meiste
licht und reflektiert nur die routen
wellenlängen zurück payments technologie
macht sich jetzt das phänomen der
interferenz zunutze interferenz bedeutet
dass sich wellen gegenseitig
beeinflussen wenn sie sich überlagern
sie können sich gegenseitig verstärken
oder abschwächen und das gilt für wellen
im wasser für schallwellen und auch viel
licht mit hilfe mehrerer sehr dünner
schichten übereinander liegen kann
peyman beeinflussen wie verschiedene
wellenlängen des lichts mit der
oberfläche interagieren
der trick ist dass die einzelnen
schichten genauso dünn sind dass das
reflektierte licht einer schicht mit dem
reflektierten licht einer anderen
schicht integriert die fifth third way
life will inter 4
also wie gesagt die botte wings da hat
es very very nice extreme die street art
cologne hat koller ist us treasuries
gewinnt art cologne im gegensatz zum
roten schal hat das material selber hier
gar nicht die farbe die es zurück
reflektiert allein durch die struktur
des materials wird eine bestimmte
wellenlänge des lichts zurückgeworfen
das ist an und für sich noch nichts
besonderes das phänomen nennt sich
optische interferenz und man findet es
sogar in der natur zb in
schmetterlingsflügeln oder in filmen auf
wasser das wirklich geniale kommt jetzt
mit hilfe eines strom impulses kann man
die struktur von einer der schichten
verändern so dass die interferenz einen
ganz anderen vorher festgelegten effekt
hat das funktioniert mit phasenwechsel
material einem stoff der zum beispiel
auch bei wiederbeschreibbaren dvds
verwendet wird durch einen einfachen
stromimpuls kann man den amorphen stoff
kristallin werden lassen
das verändert den brechungsindex und
damit die geschwindigkeit des lichts im
material plötzlich interferieren die
lichtwellen nach der reflektion anders
als vorher und von außen betrachtet kann
dadurch das material das vorher gut
aussah zum beispiel grün erscheinen
und das funktioniert mit jeder
wellenlänge oder farbe die man vorher
festgelegt hat sowohl vor als auch nach
der veränderung befindet sich das
material in einem sog
solid state einem festkörper zustand das
heißt es kostet nur energie von einem in
den anderen zustand zu wechseln
danach bleibt das material so lange in
einem zustand und somit in einer farbe
bis wieder ein impuls gegeben wird
allein für diese technologie fallen mir
schon tausende geniale
anwendungsbeispiele ein vielleicht
tapeten die auf knopfdruck ihre farbe
ändern können heute blau morgen weiß und
zur halloween-party blutrot das ganze
wurde sogar als autolack funktionieren
weil die schichten nur wenige nanometer
dick sind
sie sind flexibel aber die technologie
kann noch mehr
denn sie funktioniert auch außerhalb des
sichtbaren lichtspektrum man kann die
schichten zum beispiel auch durchsichtig
erscheinen lassen und mit ihnen nur
infrarotlicht beeinflussen
ein fenster das im sommer die wärme des
sonnenlichts draußen hält aber im winter
reinlässt kann unmengen an heizenergie
sparen
ein kleiner stromimpuls genügt um
indirekt die temperatur im ganzen raum
zu kontrollieren
peyman hat mir außerdem erzählt dass man
auch alle farben des lichts gleichzeitig
kontrollieren und somit die
lichtdurchlässigkeit von glas steuern
kann
man könnte also brillen herstellen die
mit einem schnellen tab auf dem
smartphone zu sonnenbrillen werden oder
windschutzscheiben im auto die
automatisch abdunkeln wenn man geblendet
wird
[Musik]
aber das ist alles nichts gegen die
meiner meinung nach wichtigste und
weitreichendste einsatzmöglichkeit für
diese technologie als bildschirm laut
payment kann man seine technologie in
pixel form verbauen und hat dann einen
bildschirm den mann wie jeden lcd oder
oled bildschirm mit einem computer
ansprechen kann nur mit einem riesigen
unterschied der bildschirm benötigt
keine hintergrundbeleuchtung
weil die technologie mit licht
funktioniert das auch die oberfläche
fällt und reflektiert wird könnte man
auch sein handy gucken wie auf eine
zeitschrift mit ganz natürlichem licht
aus dem raum
das hat einige große vorteile der
offensichtlichste man spart akku denn
das beleuchten unserer großen smartphone
bildschirme verbraucht mit abstand am
meisten davon aussehen würde das dann
wie das display eines kindes nur mit
farbe oder wie eine ganz normale zeitung
nur eben dass sich der inhalt bewegen
kann so ein reflektive display ist
angenehmer für die augen und dass es
besonders für gamer interessant kann
innerhalb einer mikrosekunde seinen
zustand ändern
und somit problemlos mehrere hundert
bilder pro sekunde darstellen
falls diese screen technologie so weit
entwickelt wird dass sie in reihe
produziert werden kann könnte das eine
wahre revolution für bildschirme
bedeuten screens in fenstern und
spiegeln die jederzeit durchsichtig
werden können die motorhaube als
kommunikationsplattform und
kontaktlinsen displays jede fläche im
alltag könnte ein computerbildschirm
sein und würde keinen strom verbrauchen
so lange sich der inhalt des bildes
nicht verändern soll
das klingt nach einem science fiction
film aber die technologie dazu ist heute
schon da jetzt ist es an peyman und
seinem startup weiter zu forschen und zu
testen
fehler auszubügeln und die technologie
so weit zu perfektionieren dass die
vielen anwendungsbeispiele realisiert
werden können ich bin mega gespannt wann
und wie wir wieder von ihm hören werden
so ten gebracht hat mich übrigens der
photonik campus für den ich über den
strategieprozess photonik berichtet habe
hier hat sich die branche der photonik
der wissenschaft rund ums licht
getroffen um über die wichtigsten
technologien der nächsten fünf jahre zu
sprechen
immer wichtiger werden zum beispiel die
photonik im auto und die beleuchtung in
der smart city wenn ihr mehr darüber
erfahren wollt dann schaut euch doch
meinen bericht zur kenntnis hier oben
gemacht habe und wenn ihr ein
naturwissenschaftliches fach studiert
dann könnte die photonik akademie für
euch interessant sein
dazu habe ich hier ein video gemacht
ansonsten viel einfluss zuschauern bis
zum nächsten mal
patrick